Uh,
so today we're going to continue talking
about the subject of biomechanics on,
uh,
on Tuesday we talked about their
properties of materials and,
uh, particularly alas disty and
viscosity and Bisco elasticy city.
Uh, so you know, something about
how biological materials behave,
at least in terms of how they respond
in terms of deaf formations to, uh,
forces. And certainly there's
a lot more to learn about that.
But we covered the
basics on Tuesday today.
Want to talk about how
organisms move and how they,
um,
how they move through a physical world
where they have to obey the laws of
physics.
And this is one important
role of biomechanics to
sort of understand if you're
thinking about human
biomechanics, how humans, uh,
perform as sort of mechanical machines.
And so that's one important role
of biomechanics. How organisms,
not just humans, but all
kinds of organisms function
in an engineering sense.
And a big part of that is how they have,
how they survive and not only survive
but prosper in a world where they have to
obey the laws of physics.
And it's interesting to try to understand
this because if we understood sort of
how the human machine works,
for example,
under normal conditions you can think
about how can I enhance performance in
certain, uh, in certain conditions.
And that, uh, of course is a,
is a big part of sort of
exercise physiology is
understanding how humans work
as,
as biomechanical machines.
So what we're going to talk about today
with the example I want to use as just
an example of this is motion in
biological systems in particular,
uh,
motion that humans can't do on their own
flying motions that we do all the time.
Uh,
walking and I,
I kind of motion that we do occasionally
some of us swimming and think about how
you would apply what you know about
physics to understanding those, uh,
those processes.
So why in general do organisms
have an ability to move?
Think about organisms like us
or organisms like bacteria,
all, it's a, it's a,
it's one of the essential
ingredients of life.
One of the ways that we recognize that
things are alive is because they're able
to move from one spot to another.
So why is motion so important?
Why is motion important in the life
of a, of a microorganism, uh, a,
a, a protozoa or a bacteria that swimming
allowed to run in the ocean? Why?
Why should it move? Yeah.
Define nutrients to eat, right?
To find the nutrients are substrates
that are essential to its, to its growth.
And if you think about the movements that
you make during the course of the day,
how many of them are emoted by
motivated by your need for food, right?
So that you move in order to find things
that you can eat, right? And that's,
that's one reason why living organisms
move. Why else do they move? Justin?
To avoid danger,
to get out of harm's way if you're a
microorganism won't be dangerous to you,
is often chemicals. There
might be chemicals around
you that are toxic to you.
And so you'll swim to get away from
those chemicals, right? If your, um,
if you're a a,
a rabbit in the woods,
you might be running to get
away from a fox or I'll, I'll,
I'll wolf or something that's going
to eat you. Um, if you're a human,
you might run out of prospect street
to avoid getting hit by a bus. Right?
That's, that's a good use of motion,
uh, for self preservation. Right?
Um, what one, one more key reason why,
why a animals
move
essential for propagation of the species,
not just survival of the organism.
Okay.
Justin, to reproduce, they move
to reproduce, to get together. Uh,
and that might be some of the
reasons why you move every day. Uh,
but it's certainly in the, in
the animal world, in general,
Movement for finding mates
for reproduction is an
essential part of it. So,
so easy to see why movement is critical
for not just the life of a micro
organism, not just the life
of a multicellular organism,
but for survival of the
species as well. So, uh,
movement requires force and we're going
to think about forces in particular the
forces that an organism needs to
develop somehow or generate in order to
overcome forces that resist motion.
So just some elementary physics here,
which most of you probably
remember from high school physics,
is that if an object,
the object here is this green oval,
if it's going to be moving with a
constant speed, what does that mean?
Moving with a constant speed
means not accelerating.
So there has to be some force applied
in order to create the motion,
but the forces must balance, right?
So the overall forces acting are zero,
right?
For an object that's not accelerating.
The sum of the forces is zero, right?
Because the acceleration is zero.
So if we think about this green object
moving to the right to the left,
to the
what does it for you to your left,
um,
then there must be a forest that's
creating the motion to the, to the left.
And that force is just big enough to
overcome the resistance to motion.
Okay?
That force is equally balanced
with whatever forest resist motion.
And of course the force that resists
motion is going to be different if you're
an organism that's trying to fly than
if you're an organism that's trying to
move along the ground than if you're
an organism is trying to swim, right?
So what we're going to think about today
are the forces that resist that motion
and how and how, um, how organisms
overcome that resistance.
So if we think about flight first,
then the situation is a
little bit more complicated.
What's the force that creates motion?
Well,
there's gotta be some propulsive
force that's moving us,
that's moving the organism
forward or to the left here.
There has to be some propulsive
force and that opposes the Mo,
the forest that resist that motion.
And that force is drag.
It's drag on the object
that's flying through the air.
And that drag comes from the interaction
of the surface of that object with the
air. It has to move air out of
the way in order to move ahead.
So in order to move with a constant speed,
there has to be a force that's
pushing it to the right.
And that force has to be exactly
opposite to the drag force,
which is resisting that movement.
And that drag force comes from
displacement of air, right?
The friction of air.
And you've experienced this drag force.
If you are driving in a car and you
stick your hand out the open window,
you can feel the force that's
pushing your arm backward.
In order for you to hold
your arms straight out,
you have to apply a force in the forward
direction that's directly opposed to
the forest that's from the air
that's pushing your arm back.
As the car goes faster,
takes more forced to move ahead,
right? Takes more forced
to hold it steady, right?
And so the amount of force that you need
to apply varies with the speed that you
go, right? The faster the car is going,
the more force you have to apply
to hold your arm out steady.
The faster a bird flies,
the more force it has to apply in order
to overcome this drag force that's
opposing, it's forward motion, right?
So that's the, that's the dynamics.
That's the force balance in
the horizontal direction.
Propulsive floors overcoming the
drag force, right? You know what?
It also depends on shape, right?
If you hold your arm out this way,
you hold your arm out this way you
feel a different force from the air.
All right,
so the shape or the profile of the
object that's in this field also matters,
right? Keep that in mind as
well. If you're going to fly,
there's another force you have to
overcome and that's the force of gravity.
That's the force of gravity that is
pulling you down towards the earth.
So to overcome that force,
that constant force,
there has to be a force that's moving up.
And if you're going to make,
if you're going to
maintain a constant height,
yeah,
right? A zero velocity and down with was
what you'd need to maintain. Thanks Nate.
I constant height. Then you'd have to
have a force that's lifting you up.
That's exactly opposite to the force of
gravity, right? So if you're going to fly,
you have to, you have to have
that upward force as well.
So what kinds of objects can fly?
Planes can fly.
This is a picture of an old
fashioned plane. Maybe you've,
maybe you've written on a plane that
has a propeller on it, maybe not,
but it's a little bit easier to describe,
uh,
this way that the forward force that
overcomes drag is provide provided by a
propeller that spins and creates
a force in the forward direction.
So in order to move at a
constant velocity, depending
on what that velocity is,
you have to overcome a certain amount of
drag and the propeller spins at a speed
that will provide that forced
to move forward. All right,
so that seems if not a
complete description,
that seems like a pretty adequate
description of how you move ahead, right?
But how do you get off the ground
and maintain off the ground?
It maintain your height off the ground.
In order to do that,
you have to overcome this constant force
of gravity, which is pulling you back.
That's the main problem with flight,
overcoming the force of gravity and in
airplanes that's done through design of
wings and a typical sort of air
foil or wing design is shown here.
What happens is it's
using this flow of air,
this constant flow of air over the
body, over the wings. For example,
by changing the shape so that there's
more surface area on top of the wing than
there is on the bottom.
You change the relative velocities that
air can move over the wing on over the
top of the wing versus over
the bottom of the wing,
you create a flow separation or a
disturbance here where the pressure drops
relative to the pressure
and the ambient air,
the pressure drops because of
this turbulent air flow pattern.
If there's less pressure
here than there is down here,
you get a force acting up.
Pressure is force per area, right?
So if there's a difference in
pressures from top to bottom,
more pressure on the bottom
and there isn't a top,
you'll have a lift force going up and so
you can fly if that lift force is large
enough to overcome or at least
balance the force of gravity. Right?
Does that make sense?
And you can imagine that that
lift forest varies with speed,
that you're moving through the air.
For example,
there's a critical speed you have to
reach before you get enough lift to take
off. And that I lift force
depends on the design of the, uh,
the exact shape of the wings or the air
foil certainly depends on their size,
right?
If I've got bigger wings and pressures,
what's moving me force is
pressure per area. Bigger wings,
more force up. All right, so the,
the basic physics here is
fairly straight forward.
Although implementing this,
you know, it took some time.
People have been trying to fly as long
as there were people watching birds.
Right?
But it took a while for us to figure out
how to implement this and to implement
it as reliably as we can.
Now.
So how do birds do this?
How do birds fly? Well,
the birds don't have stationary
wings typically. Right?
Although their wings can be stationary.
If you watch a hawk or
an eagle or a large bird,
they glide for a lot of their
flight once they're airborne,
right? There's a few, if you
watch, my office overlooks
the Grove Street cemetery.
There's some hawks that live in the,
in the cemetery.
Must be a good place for
hawks. Um, but uh, they,
they take off and then they
glide for long periods.
They can circle and there's very
little motion of their wings.
They're basically doing,
they're taking advantage of the forward
thrust that they've created and they're
coasting,
but their wings are doing this.
So they're holding their wings in a
position that creates an air foil,
creates the pressure drop to move them up,
but to take off or to create this
forward thrust, they move their wings,
right?
They don't have propellers,
so they use their wings to create thrust
by sort of pushing them against the air
backwards, right? Creating a forward
thrust, which overcomes the drag.
Yet their wings are shaped like an
air foil. So they create thrust,
they bring them back into the air
foil position, they get lift, right?
So it's more complicated than what I'm
describing, but you can see, you know,
beating your wings like this,
creating thrust in one direction,
holding them in a position where you
create lift and then varying between those
two things. You can both move forward
and supply the lift you need to overcome.
The force of gravity.
If you watch different kinds of birds,
you'll see that they execute
different kinds of patterns.
And they do that because
they're different, right?
Some birds are smaller than
others, some are, some are bigger,
some have different shaped wings,
different shaped bodies.
And so their particular motion is that
adapted to the physics of their body and
their need to move it through the air.
So,
um, I talked a bit about wing size. Right?
Wing size is one thing that you could
use in an airplane, for example,
bigger wings, more upward
lift, bigger wings of course,
heavier. So it's, if it's heavier,
it's going to require a bigger engine,
right?
So that you can get the thrust
needed to move at a certain velocity.
But if you look at birds have different
sizes or flying animals of any kind of
different sizes,
you'll notice that there's a correlation
between the size of the winning and the
size of the animal.
The bigger the bird,
typically the bigger the wings
for just that reason. Bigger,
heavier needs more lift in
order to get up into the air.
Uh,
you also notice other kinds of adaptions
that birds that have big wings,
big bodies also tend to have strong legs,
right?
Little birds,
isn't it?
Amazing little birds you see
perched on a tree limb or something.
Very small legs, right? Big Birds, hawks,
falcons, eagles, strong legs. Why
would a big bird needs strong legs?
Sorry. Without, they use,
they actually pick up pray and
things. And so they use them for, uh,
for acquiring food. That's, that's, that's
a good reason. Yeah. Why, why for flow?
Do they need them for flight? Yeah,
they need to be able to lift off.
And so to get that initial,
maybe they get some boost from
their legs in the lift off phase,
some forward thrust and some
upward lift just from the,
just from the muscular
structure of their legs.
And they're not always in flight,
right?
They need to land sometimes and
they land on their legs typically.
Right. And if you're going to bring
a big object down to the ground,
there's going to be some
force involved with that.
You need large legs in order
to survive that force. Right.
And so just giving you some examples of
how the physical structure of animals is
adapted to their function.
And a lot of it is their function
as mechanical objects, right?
It's a familiar concept,
but one can,
one can sort of break it
apart and interesting,
kind of a bird is shown here.
A hummingbird,
you ever watched a hummingbird?
Hummingbirds do something
that's really amazing.
They hover,
which means they can stay up in the
air without having any forward thrust.
I mean when I was talking
about the airplane example
or even the bird example I
was talking about using the forward motion
supplied by thrust in order to create
the pressure drop that brings you up.
But if you stop moving forward,
that pressure drop disappears.
You go down, right?
So forward motion is required for an
airplane to stay up in the air for a bird.
Most birds to stay up in
the air, hummingbirds can
hover, which is a remarkable,
uh,
physical achievement.
And they do that because they can actually
turn their wings in both directions.
They can turn them upside down.
And that's shown in this diagram here
that they can make the wing go backward
and forward and turn it right side up
and upside down so they can create a
motion where they're creating no net
forward thrust or backward thrust,
but always creating lift because
they're changing the position or the
orientation of their wings.
And a more complicated than that.
If you're interested,
I'm sure you can find information on it,
but again they can do this because they
have specially designed wings that can
flip over during their motion.
They have the muscles that allow them
to make this kind of emotion and they're
fairly small so they don't need much lift
force in order to keep them a loft to
overcome the problem of gravity.
So hummingbirds can hover because they
generate lift in both the upstroke and
the downstroke.
So as long as their wings are in motion,
they're constantly creating lift
and so they stay off the ground.
Okay.
That's something about a flight,
which is interesting and I think maybe
the simplest one to to think about cause
one can break down the forces
that are involved fairly easily.
Let's think about walking
and running or a mode.
Nobody flew here this morning.
You've got here to class somehow.
How did you get here? Um,
most of you probably walked.
Maybe some of you ran. Uh, but uh,
most of you probably walked. Why?
Of all the,
of all the choices that you had,
why did you walk instead of slithering
on the ground or crawling or running?
Why did, why did you walk?
Why did you make that choice?
You might not even thought about it.
You probably didn't get to the room,
to the door of your room and say,
should I crawl, slither, run or walk?
You probably just started walking.
Why was that your first choice,
Justin?
It comes naturally.
And why do you think that's your natural
motion for moving along the surface of
the earth? Why is that your
natural, your natural choice?
Why have you decided even
without thinking about it,
that that's your normal mode of motion?
Yeah,
it's the easiest. It's
the least resistance. It's
the most efficient, right?
It's the most efficient way to
move from one place to another.
And it's efficiency. That's important.
Now, how would you define efficiency here?
How much energy did you need to
expand to get from your room to here?
And how can you get from your room to
hear minimizing the amount of energy that
you spend? That's the, that's the
subconscious decision that you make.
And the answer is that you walk,
right?
And so what force are you
overcoming when you're walking here?
What's the force that opposes your motion?
You know,
the forest to create your motion is the
movement of the muscles of your leg and
your skeleton, right? So like
rocking back and forth like this.
I'm using my muscles to
create motion side to side.
And you use a similar
strategy when you walk.
But what force am I
overcoming when I do this?
Or what force did you have to
overcome in order to get here?
While you're not there is a drag
force cause you're moving through air.
So just like, just
like, um, a flying bird,
you're experiencing drag
from the atmosphere,
but it turns out that that's not as
large as the frictional of your body
touching the ground. Right?
And so when you walked,
you probably didn't walk like with your
feet on the ground because that would
take a lot of energy, you know, try it,
try walking back home with your
feet constantly on the ground.
That takes a lot more
energy than picking them up.
But you pay a price for picking them up,
right?
And then now you're introducing
another problem, actually two problems.
And that when you pick up a foot,
you have to overcome gravity.
So you're using some of your motion to
go in the wrong direction instead of
moving towards class, you're moving
up, right? You're picking your leg up,
which is not getting you any
closer to where you want to be,
but you pick it up in order to release
it from the frictional forces that are,
um, that are holding it back. Right.
The frictional forces that resist motion.
So how do you walk then?
You don't walk with your feet
constantly in contact with the ground.
Although that would be easier in a sense,
because if your feet
are both on the ground,
balance is not so hard once you
lift the foot off the ground.
The other problem that
introduces is balance.
And it's much harder for me
to stay stationary on one
leg than it is on two legs
because gravity's acting on my body
and trying to pull me back down again.
So an additional problem arises with this
lifting up of one foot and that is the
problem of balance.
And how do we solve that?
We solved that by controlling our muscles,
the muscles that move us from side
to side maybe, but that takes energy.
So I want to move forward.
And the easiest way is to walk.
And you probably didn't think about
it when you were walking here today,
but you're doing a fairly
complicated set of operations, right?
You're lifting one foot off the ground
to avoid gravity and you're letting it
swing forward. The heel of your
forward foot hits the ground,
your foot then moves the
toe of your back foot,
leaves the ground swings forward,
heel strike,
toe lift, swing, heel strike, toe lift,
swing one foot's always on
the ground when you walk,
you don't think about it,
but it's a fairly complicated motion
that you can do automatically now.
But if you do think about it,
when you're walking to your next class,
you'll notice that one foot is always on
the ground and that helps you solve the
problem of balance. All right? That
helps you solve the problem of balance.
What else happens when you're,
uh, when you're doing this motion,
and you might not notice it at all,
but your pelvis is actually undergoing
a fairly complicated set of movements.
I'm going to exaggerate it
so you can't laugh, right?
But if you watch somebody else walk or
you put your hands on your pelvic bone,
the pelvic bone is,
this is this sort of girdle that
both of your hips are connected too,
right? You've seen it on a
skeleton and when I lift up my leg,
then I'm tilting my pelvis up,
right?
I'm tilting this site up in order
to get the leg off the ground.
I'm also bending my knee a little bit
to make my leg shorter and I'm moving my
foot in order to allow
when the toe lifts off,
allow it to swing without
hitting the ground.
You don't want to hit the
ground because of friction.
That would be a waste of energy.
You want to lift it just enough so that
you clear the ground and you do that by
tilting your pelvis up and by bending
your knee a little and manipulating your
foot, you let that leg
swing forward, the toe hits,
and now you're doing something else with
your pelvis and that you're going like
this, right? You're not only
lifting up to get it off the ground.
And then up on the other side,
you're also twisting it like this.
So your pelvis twists your pelvis
tilt and it actually undergoes,
if you could put a sort of,
I'm exaggerating it,
maybe not as much as others could,
but I'm trying to exaggerate that your
hips sort of go through a figure eight
kind of motion as you're moving forward.
It's a fairly complicated motion that
you do without even thinking about it
because you've done a lot of walking
and you've learned how to do it very
efficiently. All right,
this is makes sense.
So if you look at the
efficiency of walking,
um,
you are creating forward motion.
You're creating it in
opposition to friction.
You're doing it by lifting a foot off
the ground, freeing it from friction,
swinging it forward. The cost is
you had spent some energy going up,
you spend some energy going up,
and then you recover that
energy when you come back down.
What's energy called that
you store as you move up?
Potential energy.
And so one of the other things that
happens if you notice somebody walking,
and it's hard to notice if you just see
me walking like this, maybe you can,
but my head is actually moving up and
down when I walk because my center of
gravity is rising and falling as I pick
my leg off the ground and let it swing.
And you can't see that so easily
when you're watching a whole,
but have you ever seen somebody walk
with a fence in front of them and you see
their head and it moves
up and down a little bit?
So there's an entire conversion there
between potential energy when I'm up and
kinetic energy when I'm down,
right?
So I can exaggerate it that
way too if I walk funny. Um,
that you're putting some of your
energy into potential energy,
creating potential
energy with your muscles,
and then recovering that
when you come back down.
But the more of that you have to do,
the more energy it takes.
And so these moat movements of
the pelvis I mentioned before,
sort of smooth out this up and down
movement so you're not wasting so much
energy going up and down.
You're mainly going forward,
right?
So if you walked,
did anybody walk here with somebody
walk by yourself or did you walk him?
Anybody walking in a pair.
Okay.
Nobody wants to admit they
walked with him. Well,
have you ever walked with somebody else?
Did you ever notice that sometimes
when you're walking with somebody else,
they want to go faster than you or
they want to go slower than you.
Okay.
Why is that? Why do some people
walk more slowly than others?
Okay.
Why do some people walk
more quickly than others?
Their legs are longer,
so their bodies are shaped differently.
So they've figured out how to make
their walking efficient for them.
Right.
And that means they figured out how to
do this motion with their body and the
most efficient way.
Now,
why would longer legs make it more
efficient to move faster? Well,
cause when you swing your leg you get
a bigger bang for the buck, right?
You get farther with one stride.
That's part of it.
The other part is that your leg,
when it's in this swing motion,
behaves like another object. You've
probably studied in physics. The pendulum.
Okay.
Right.
You've seen pendulums that swing.
You noticed that the timing of pendulums.
Anybody have a metronome?
Yeah.
Metronomes are pendulums like that too,
that have an adjustable weight.
Right? If you move the
weight one way or the other,
then the pendulum starts swinging at a
different frequency and depending on the
length and weight of
your leg as a pendulum,
it has a natural frequency
at which it wants to swing
as a natural frequency at
which it wants to swing.
If I want to walk with
the least energy possible,
I want to just let my leg swing. I don't
want to put any energy into it, right?
I'll put some energy into lifting it
off the ground, but once I lifted off,
it's back here. What if I can just
let it go and it swings forward?
That's the most efficient motion
and that motion would have a timing.
That depends on the size of your body
and the length of your leg and the weight
of your leg and all the
other characteristics that
are particular to you.
If I want to walk slower
than my natural state,
I have to slow something down,
right?
So my leg might swing forward
fast with a certain distance.
In order for me to move slower,
I have to actually slow down my leg.
I have to slow down the swing forward.
That takes energy.
It takes muscles to slow down.
And so sometimes that you feel like if
you're walking more slowly than you want
to, that it's actually taking more
energy than it should. Likewise,
if you have to walk faster
than your normal pace,
it will seem like and will be that you're
using more energy than you would like
to.
Yeah,
so walking has an efficiency. You
can change your speed. Of course.
You've learned how to do that.
But if you plot on a graph like this one,
this is a graph for a typical
person who's walking on a flat,
uh,
outdoor surface.
And what it shows is the Blue Line there
shows the efficiency or how much energy
you use as a function of speed of walking,
how much energy uses a function of speed,
right?
So there's a flat part at the beginning,
not too much different if I'm
below two miles an hour walking,
it takes about the same amount of energy,
right?
It takes about the same amount of
energy, but as, but as speed goes up,
the energy consumption goes up.
Do you have to walk faster,
faster than your natural stride?
And so you're using more energy maybe
to swing your leg forward faster so that
you can walk. You might even,
if you start walking fast,
try this on your way to the next class or,
or tried to rob,
walk with somebody and watch
them as you walk faster,
your heads going up and down
more, right? You're, you're,
you're taking advantage of this potential
kinetic transition to get more speed.
But the cost of that is that you're
moving your body up and down more.
And so that is less efficient cause
movement up and down. It's wasted,
right? At a certain point, you see the
Blue Line goes up and up and up and,
and it's, it's exponential. If
you, it starts to look exponential.
If you continue to try to
walk faster and faster,
it's going to eventually start
to become really uncomfortable.
Yeah.
And you're naturally going to want to
switch to a different form of motion and
that's running. Now. You can avoid that,
right? And you could try this yourself,
try walking faster and faster and faster.
And don't let yourself run.
Just walk faster and faster.
And pretty soon you're doing that crazy
kind of walk that Olympic fast walkers
do. Right. That feels very unnatural. Uh,
you might get a lot of speed, but it
feels very unnatural. I'm not, you know,
you're kind of, can anybody
do it? You've seen it. Uh,
but you,
you're moving up and down a lot.
Your pelvis is doing a
very unusual pattern,
not the subtle movements that
it does during a normal walking,
but it's moving a lot more and that's
what you notice. The fast walkers,
they're moving from side to side. Their
pelvis is really moving a lot, right?
It becomes quite inefficient
because you're wasting
energy and in fact your body
is telling you to make the
transition from walking into running.
If I want to move this at this speed,
it's more efficient for me to run and
that's what this graph shows you as well.
If you extended the walking line up a
little bit at a speed of about five miles
per hour, running becomes
more efficient than walking
and you can feel that transition.
If you try to walk fast,
there will become a point at about five
miles per hour when you're going to want
to start to run because that will feel
like a more efficient way for your body
to move. Now, what is it that
causes that mechanically,
that transition to take place? What's
different about running than walking?
Well,
one of the things that's different is
that you don't always have one foot on the
ground when you're running
back to you watch somebody
run or you run yourself.
You'll know that for a lot
of the time you're only,
you're not no foot's on the ground.
There's no time that both feet are
on the ground, right? One foot hits,
you sort of bounce off of it,
you bounce off the other one,
you're sort of hopping off one foot,
tried to do that slow. It's
really hard. Why is that hard?
Because it's hard to balance on one foot.
It's impossible to balance on no feet,
right when you are standing still,
but as your speed increases,
you create, you create inertia,
you create forward motion and that
forward motion or inertia stabilizes your
body. It makes balance
less of an issue, right?
If you're moving forward
at five miles an hour,
you're not worried about sideways motion
so much because you have this forward
motion which is going to continue to carry
you forward and balance isn't so much
of a problem anymore and
so you can sacrifice.
Having both feet on the ground.
You can even sacrifice having any foot
on the ground for some period and you'll
just fly
and you'll fly forward.
No balance is required so you're
not spending any energy on balance.
Alright, so running is sort of like flight
in a way only. It's very short flight.
It's like flying and hopping,
hopping on one foot.
Also at that speed when you're
moving at five miles an hour,
if you see somebody that's
running particularly an
experienced runner and what
makes experienced runners better
than inexperienced runners,
they've become more efficient at doing
this running motion. And so they can,
they can, they can move it
fast, speeds very efficiently.
And one of the things you'll
notice in very efficient,
fast runners are good runners,
is that there's very little up
and down motion of their head.
Even though they're hopping and flying,
they're not moving up and down very much.
They've learned how to do this without
moving very much in the gravitational
field, keeping their center
of gravity about the same,
which allows them to convert all of
their energy into forward motion.
Just makes sense.
There's another peculiar thing on this
slide and it's the black line cycling,
and if I told you that you had to move
this afternoon at 12 miles per hour to
get from here to somewhere else in
new haven in a couple of minutes,
most of you,
if you had the choice,
would choose to use a bicycle to do
that rather than walking and running,
particularly in new, you had to move
that fast, you'd pick a bicycle,
and so it won't be surprising for you to
see that cycling is much more efficient
at higher speeds than either
walking or running, right?
So if I want to move 12 miles an hour,
cycling is much more efficient than
running walking's not even shown here
because it would be so much less
efficient. On the other hand,
it doesn't make obvious
sense, right? Because you are,
you're going to agree to move fast,
not with your,
not only with your body,
but with another thing as well,
which adds weight, right? Even even a,
even a very lightweight
bicycle weighs 30 pounds.
So you're adding 30 pounds to your weight,
but you would gladly do that if you knew
you had to move fast because you know
it's going to be more efficient.
Why is cycling so much more
efficient than running? Well,
one for one reason is when you're cycling,
you're sort of in a constant profile.
You're moving your legs, but your center
of gravity stays relatively uniform.
Your center of gravity stays relatively
uniform, very little up and down.
So all of your motion,
all of your energy that's created by your
legs is converted into forward motion.
The other thing you know is
that now you have a mechanical,
you have a machine that's going to convert
the energy of your legs efficiently
into motion of a wheel.
And that wheel overcomes friction very
efficiently by actually using friction.
It's friction between the wheel and the
ground that keeps the bicycle stable and
allows it to generate high speeds.
Alright?
So this machine allows you to overcome
the problems of friction and gravity,
uh, very, uh, very smoothly.
And so cycling is a much
more efficient activity.
A Lot's been written about
the biomechanics of cycling.
If you're interested in learning
more about that? Well, I want to, uh,
talk about, uh, swimming. Another
mode that we, uh, that we, uh,
use not every day. Some of you might
swim every day. Most people don't.
Microorganisms that live in the ocean,
fish that live in water, of course,
swim all the time and swimming as their
primary motive motion and they swim to
get food, get away from danger,
reproduce all of those things.
So what's the major problem that you
have to overcome when you swim? Well,
it's friction or drag.
It's the same problem really,
that all movement has to overcome,
but we're not thinking so much
about friction on the earth.
Now we're thinking more about the drag
force that's created from moving through
a fluid.
It's a bigger problem now because
the fluid is viscous, right?
Air has a relatively low bus viscosity.
You know what this Gossett he has from
Tuesday's lecture air has a relatively
low viscosity.
Water has an higher viscosity,
molasses or honey has an
even higher viscosity,
but it's harder to move through water
than it is through air because it's
thicker.
It's harder to slip the plains of
packets of water past each other.
To go back to the description,
I gave you a viscosity last time,
and in fact,
if you're going to swim,
if you're going to swim
at a constant velocity,
then you have to create a
propulsive force moving forward.
That is exactly opposite to the drag
force that is created by moving at that
velocity. And just like the example
of putting your arms out in the,
of a moving vehicle,
which I don't recommend,
right?
Sorry, I'm using it as an example
because we've all done it,
but I don't recommend
experiments of that kind.
Imagine that you were putting
your hand out in water.
The same kind of thing would
happen, right? Only the
force would be even greater,
right?
The force would be even greater because
of the greater viscosity of the water.
Um,
so you have to create a bigger propulsive
force and over to overcome this drag.
And that's what fish have to do. That's
what microorganisms that swim have to do.
Most microorganisms that swim for a
living or most fish that swim for a living
have evolved mechanisms to
move quickly through water by,
uh,
by reducing their profile.
So fish often have streamlined
shapes. They might be flat, right?
They look like flat plates,
sometimes some kinds of fish.
So that's an easier shape.
A more streamlined shape creates less
drag as it moves through water than a
bulky shape, like a
cube or a sphere, right?
So streamlining or shape is an adaptation
that animals can use in order to move
faster. You know this, if you swim,
if you want to swim and just
glide through the water, right?
Push off from the side and just glide.
If you go like this,
you're not going to collide very far.
If you put your hands in front of yourself
or down at your side and make your
body more streamlined, you're
going to go a long ways, right?
So streamlining helps,
it turns out that there's a very simple
relationship between the drag force and
the velocity that you move forward for
objects that are spiritual or roughly
spiritual. And, um, I
show that equation here.
The drag force is equal to six Pi Times
the speed or the velocity that you're
moving times the viscosity times the size.
And here the size would be the
radius of the sphere, right?
This equation applies to spheres,
so it applies very well to
objects like microorganisms,
like bacteria that aren't
entirely spiritual,
but they're not too different
from spiritual either.
And if I am this bacterium and I
want to move with a constant speed,
I have to create a force that exactly
overcomes this drag force that's created.
And that drag force depends on speed.
To move faster,
I have to overcome a bigger drag force.
I have to create more propulsive force,
right? Just like the airplane,
a fish, the same thing.
In order for it to move
forward at a certain speed,
it has to overcome the drag force.
And it does that by moving its muscles,
by moving its flippers and thins
to create a propulsive force.
I what I did here is a simple calculation
between different kinds of swimmers,
swimmers that are basically different
in their size, uh, for a bacterium.
Okay?
It's very small.
It's size is 0.01 centimeter.
That's about one micron.
So a very small object. Um,
I asked the question how much,
how much,
um,
if I asked the question,
how much drag force is created
for it to move at a certain speed?
And what was a reasonable speed? I picked
a speed of 10 body lengths per second.
Okay.
10 body lengths per second would be a
speed of 0.01 centimeter per second.
So just multiply this by 10 per second,
right?
And the viscosity of
water is 0.01, um, uh,
one centipoise or 0.01 gram
per centimeter per second.
So if you knew these factors,
you knew how big the bacterium was,
you knew the viscosity of the
meeting and it's going through,
you knew how fast it was going to move.
You could plug into this equation
and calculate the drag force.
So if you calculate the drag force,
that's how much force that object has
to be generating in order to move,
right? You could do the same thing
for a fish. Now fish is bigger.
It's say lots of different sizes of fish.
But let's say a 10 centimeter fish moving
through the same medium moves 10 body
lengths per second, that would be
a hundred centimeters per second.
Okay.
And a Yale student who wants to swim
might have a size of about 170 centimeters
larger than the fish or the bacterium
to move 10 body lengths per second that
can, I converted that to miles per
hour. That's about half a mile per hour.
Okay.
I don't know. I'm not a
swimmer. Is that fast?
Okay.
Sounds fast as much. It's, it's
slower than you normally walk, right?
But you can't swim it as
fast as you can walk. Uh,
so let's just use that as an estimate and
it's moving through the same viscosity.
So one of the things I asked you to do
in the homework for next week is to take
this data and,
and sort of consider what life
is like for a swimming bacteria,
for a swimming fish, for
swimming, Yale student,
just with, with these factors
in mind, their sizes, viscosity,
the meeting the same and their speeds
of motion a somewhat different.
So you'll have a chance
to think about this, um,
quantitatively for next time and
we'll come back to it in section.
I want to finish by talking about another
element to biomechanics that I hope
where I'm able to talk a little bit
more about a couple of weeks from now.
And that's the issue of
design in biomechanics.
And one of the main issues of design
and biomechanics is the design of
artificial artificial replacements for
joints like the hip and artificial hip
replacements have now been
around for hundreds of years.
We are quite skilled at making
artificial hip replacements.
Surgeons are quite skilled at doing them.
A surgeon who does a lot
of hip replacements can do
an operation like this and
about an hour that includes, uh, you know,
taking your diseased hip out,
putting an artificial hip back in and
getting you to the postop all in about an
hour.
And it's a pretty remarkable,
a pretty remarkable achievement
from the surgical side.
I want to show you a little bit about
how these work from the biomedical
engineering side. And to do that, I
first wanted to show you the hip joint,
which you might've seen so before,
but this is a skeleton.
This is half of the pelvis
I was talking about before.
It's motion during walking.
You see half of it here.
So this is the person's midline.
This is the right hip, the pelvis,
the crest there. If you, if you put your
own fingers on the sides of your hips,
you can feel the bone that sort of
sticks out at the top about where my belt
lies here.
That's the crest of the Ilium,
or one of the bones that makes up the
pelvis for the experiment you're going to
do while you're going to your next class,
where you think about how your pelvis
moves. Keep your fingers there.
That will be convenient and
silly if you walk that way. Uh,
but the hip is connected right
below that, right? And you can feel,
if you feel down a little bit
from the crest of your Ilium,
you can feel this part of a long bone
called the femur that makes up the thigh,
right? It's the bone of your, of
your, uh, the upper part of your leg.
And that bone extends down
to your knee this way,
and it connects to your
pelvis this way through a, uh,
through a structure that's a continuous
structure of the bone called the femoral
neck and the femoral head.
And what it looks like
is a neck and a head.
The head being sort of a ball and the
ball of the femur fits into a cup in the
pelvis and it is this
ball moving in this cup,
which gives your hip, it's
range of motion, right?
In your hip has a
remarkable range of motion.
You can move it all different sorts of
ways, not just forward and backward,
but you can move it to the side,
right?
And it's a ball moving in a cup
that creates all of this, uh,
versatility of motion, right? You can
swing it around different ways. Well,
when this joint gets diseased,
movement becomes much more difficult. And
in general, it's a degenerative disease,
uh, that the, the bones and the
cartilage start to break down.
And so now this cup and, and, uh,
ball don't move so
smoothly over one another.
And when they don't move smoothly
over another, they generate friction.
They generate pain, right?
And so degenerating hips caused can
cause tremendous amounts of pain, uh,
for, uh, people.
So what's in between these two
in this is just a skeleton,
so there's nothing in between these two,
but in our hips,
what is it that lubricates the
space between the hip of the,
the, the, the cup in the pelvis
and the ball of the femur?
What lubricates that space?
There's some fluid there,
but the main thing that lubricates it is
a protective layer of cartilage or soft,
uh, soft skeletal material,
not bone, but it's soft,
spongy material that
lubricates between bones.
And that can break down in
diseases like arthritis. Well,
this is what an artificial hip looks like.
It's the modern hip is
composed of two parts.
There's a cup which goes into your pelvis
that replaces the normal structures
into which the theme or goes.
So it replaces the cartilage and the
bony structure around the pelvis and the
end of the Femur,
the neck.
And the head are replaced by a piece of
metal and the metal sets in the metal
ball of the femur.
Artificial femurs sets in the cup of the,
of the pelvis.
Now what lubricates it now is
not Cartlidge but a polymer.
Because if you had a metal cup and a
metal theme or going in metal on metal,
even if it was very smooth metal,
that's not,
there's friction associated
with that motion.
But if you put a polymer in particular,
what what are used most often now is,
is high density polyethylene
or something like Teflon.
A metal ball slides very
easily over a Teflon Cup,
particularly if their machine to fit
together precisely. And so that's what,
that's what,
uh,
is used currently and what allows
normal motion to be restored.
Now the problem,
the main problem here is how to get
this ball and this neck attached to the
femur. Because if you think about
it, why is it metal? It's metal.
Because if you're standing on one leg,
all of the weight of your
body is on that one leg.
The whole weight of your body is on the
femur the whole way that the body is
actually right here.
Okay?
Right. The whole weight of your
body is on this very small,
depends on the integrity of that
very small piece of material.
And what we learned last time is that
materials have elasticy city, right?
You don't want something
that bends a lot there.
You want something that's strong that
doesn't bend even when there's a high
stress applied to it,
like the stress of the weight of your
body and metals are really the materials
that best can supply that
kind of mechanical strength,
that kind of resistance to
bending resistance to fracture.
So the problem is how to get this on here.
The way that that solved currently is to
have the neck and the ball of the femur
attached to a much longer piece of metal.
When you get an artificial hip than this
part of the new replacement femur goes
down into the bone of your leg,
okay.
Inserted into the bone so
that it's more stable, right?
There's all of this metal into your
bone to sort of stabilize it because the
last thing you want or what you
want to achieve is for this,
this part of the Femur to move without
any slippage with the rest of your femur.
Okay. I'm going to come back
to this, uh, this concept, uh,
later and talk more when we
talk about artificial organs,
about how artificial hips are made.
But I wanted you to at least have a
picture of how this particular piece of
biomedical engineering works.
We'll see it's section this afternoon.